[Music]
hi everybody I'm Jonathan shrimps and
today we're over here at the first floor
of the world chess hall of fame and I'm
proud to announce that we have a very
special event a norm tournament coming
up the 2017 st. Louis winter
Invitational they'll take place on in
February februari 16th to the 21st and
to determine the order of the Lots we're
going to play a very special game here
we got two of our pristine members that
are going to play in a very interesting
game of chess and for all the rules of
the game we're going to throw it over to
Mike comer who's going to be the arbiter
of the event to explain the rules here
thank you very much Jonathan so I will
be playing a classical game of chess but
this time it'll be with juice glasses
all right so it will mix it up just a
little bit more and Mario roper will be
playing The Hurt move James IV and every
time a piece is captured whoever is is
up if there's a number that will
correspond with their Perry number for
the event and here's Johnson all right
thank you very much Mike and Mario last
time we did the Lots here did not go in
your favor do you have any different
strategy here it is chest so it is a
little bit of a different game I don't
know I just want to have fun with this
is a lovely wine set so I just don't
want to damage anything Wow capturing
yeah this is like one of their best sets
here it's the main attraction and
they've been very nice to let us play
with it James you are defending your
title are you going to be able to beat
mario again well I have really
intentions of doing like I normally do
and just put the hurt movement of faint
sounds good so with that in mind James
will go ahead and take your spot Mario
you'll take your spot and we'll get this
thing going all right we're ready to go
the players are shaking hands white
grape juice moves first
alright a very careful d4 also be on the
players to remember where all the pieces
are ya don't lose don't lose track of
where the pieces are ok Mario all right
Maya plays d5 ok here comes the night ok
a very careful Knight to f3 and now we
will see are the players going to drink
any of the juice today that's what we're
going to find out as soon as we get a
capture here pony whispers I that's why
we can't have nice things right all
right first of all of you three
ah there you think Tourette's
interesting twist oh okay all right
excellent great move great move okay
wonderful good pace gasoline so the
reason why they're playing like good
chest instead of just like crazy chest
here is because they're whoever wins
this game gets a free entry into the
Metro class championship that will be
held this Saturday februari fourth at
the Chess Club the winner of each class
gets two hundred dollars yeah so lots of
play for so so we can kind of you know
it's okay that they're playing so good
salut solicit thank you reach more
suspense for the players waiting for the
pairings Oh as I predicted before the
match a [ __ ] up to four as well see
all right might be 2d to you look at
thirsty more you look at thirsty just
take it to take it drink up and the
players that are up right now our Andre
gorvich for the GM and Michael Brooks
for the I am norm tournament all right
we got our first capture when Mario
drink a number there so spots for a
second mike wants to announce it it's
number eight as I see it like glass
number eight is a really glad of it all
right excellent job first one and there
was a number that's what we want to see
for the GM is angel lopez from spain and
aaron grub in ski from webster all right
I'm expecting a capture here strongly
expecting a capture what will it be with
all right with the ninth and that is a
mobile say we'll see if these are you
going to go for it that's do you Mario
Oh is he going for the whole thing pace
yourself there's a lot of pieces of this
board oh and I see it number nine
excellent that's good two captures to
lot numbers who's up next we have a
wonder leg and my man the calc Ubar
we're doing very well lately rating just
keeps going up go ahead Mario are you
ready
alright
okay oh it was on the game but it was on
the camp he is known for playing be four
in crazy positions but we didn't see
that here today layup capsule on the
Kings side oh good there's some pond
tension there could be some captures
he's going for it he's going for it all
right we'll have to check and see if
there's a number let's have a look stop
we went to recapture
whether it's gonna do all right you
think for the pond and you're gonna do
it again all right good go be the one
pink all right perfect moment three
mulberry
all right basics I did finish the whole
thing now the game is getting
interesting I have a prediction and my
prediction was correct Bishop to be too
all right those what you going going
back going back all right buddy song
alright knew how to move that piece low
I guess yeah they both look very funny
ok love it see AMI we get now provide
some love ooh the first Queen move of
the game 30 look at that someone's gonna
I'm gonna get taken soon I'm good that's
always want to see sorry I realize that
as we go along it's harder and harder to
tell the pieces don't look like regular
pieces here so a wonder leang and nikhil
kumar well this could really decide
their fate you know what I'm saying if
you know
James to move here comes you gonna take
something oh alright he did not take he
did not take okay yeah yeah all right
oh there we go you gotta capture with
the bishop to be all right and is there
a number that's the big question here
there is this number seven awesome so we
have seven ages I'll write and two cups
was enough yet to yet to see if Mario
will consume any juice okay so up for
the GF dorm tournament is John Michael
Burke and by telling nemer for the IM
norm tournament all right protected his
pin piece so that was smart we're almost
ten Oh hard to tell you better you got
to remember where your stuff is here
comes loose there he goes Oh nine eight
seven seven good cuz he's threatening to
trade keep threatening to trade to we're
happy
between us it does we have a tactic I
minute places he needs to be another
event with the 30 players well it's kind
of royal just like like here and it's a
level two so they both here because the
Metro class championship is on the line
almost too good of a prize for 50 bucks
all right Mario it's a big capture the
business gun gauntlet all right we got
our first taste of juice you ever had
white grape juice before mario has been
a while all right it's been a while
excellent yeah good more captures James
gets a pass hold a connected pass pull
no not them all right good tip keepig
and stuff to eat fake and stuff yeah do
not forget about that sneaky night
that's nothing you take enough only want
to say fortunately it doesn't look like
it nope flinging a slightly quieter
environment that we did last time at
barrio puts his night in a pin what was
he thinking all right okay to see one
morning this past pong that's always got
going for himself from this position
it'll a very very difficult position a
lot of room to go go wrong especially
when you're not seeing the traditional
pieces here
sneaky move and the queens and the rooks
look a lot alike the queen is only an
inch taller at most so it could easily
get confusing now if one illegal move
will make bensimon cry like it really
meant by it might end the game actually
we're counting on you guys going back
back it up alright
I'm right was the time right I was down
a bishop but earlier today I fought on
that game we were have to talk about the
conclusion or who you were playing it
doesn't matter a fought he fought he's a
warrior I got the glory of every 10 the
bishop is in a pen is this mario fun
fact a one the place can place will be
complete for ok 8r ok one my ship early
yeah no place like home baby
I'll at all okay everybody's going back
everybody's going back to be eight we go
can we trade here any second I really
feel like there's gonna be a treat All
Right see a trade which night was that
does anybody know no man it's gonna be
really tough to mine the bells were here
really well that guy went home right
announcing oh yeah all good deal maybe I
see a six maybe I see you think well
John Michael Burke of Italian no matter
what your number six the red ones it's
hard to tell yeah so we have six seven
eight nine off the board all the good
ones oh so yeah so we can almost
so next up is David he's a GM from
hungry and alle fallen wha who got his
first international master time and he's
returning we'll see if he can do it
again good news for allophones your
parry number 4 excellent yeah this is a
good one you want one through five all
right we got another one we got another
one is that Queen hard to tell but I
don't see anything so now we have a
hooah st. Louis archbishop is on the
clock right now he goes by JJ allen
morality and international master from
Turkey and a brother of another
archbishop former archbishop Joel bunola
brother was a archbishop backin off the
early we hopping around carefully
maneuvering around the other we've only
spilled one so that's actually a pretty
good sign learning curve yeah if anybody
could tell me the score of just I'm
happy to know but this music been
finally put in the background it's just
fantastic it's really made it feel like
we're speeding along as this game was
being played I have a feeling only eight
people are watching right now been fine
gold Nicholas chicka Bow z tato jefra
colas justice jury and henschel young
not so much of the two players on the
clock JJ Joel bottom mostly good numbers
left
oh yeah there we go second what I look
yeah you do not want to get back rank
checkmated because you don't know
where's the rooks are you hard to know
it's almost similar to like playing
blindfold chess if you haven't played
blindfold because these are not standard
pieces so yeah you really have to
concentrate and remember what pieces of
witches I was like damn ground poaching
yeah essentially that's what it is you
know we'll see who the better blindfold
player is it's a slight improvement over
blindfold but it's difficult so
understandable they're taking a lot of
time and everybody's like laughing at
home cuz I see the nice board next to it
all right longest stuff keeps
threatening to take other stuff
everybody's happy
is a deep point revealed normally I'd
recommend you just put your bishop as
far away as possible but here it doesn't
even matter because it's so unclear it
also player a plus that would uh you
know you don't want to get back row
checkmate take away a flight square
right a very and very smart as a matter
for the bishops way they still won't be
a comment in this game this is on g3 if
I normally get you go really far away
but oh oh f five bishops that's James
let's yep once a pension love it there's
stuff to drink I never know
all right excellent we got a trade we
got a trade maybe Mariela to know who
asked fuzzy fell far the trick I've got
home for the guy with the pad pause okay
it's my prediction although I can't tell
who's planning or loose seeker all I
know isn't got to pass like The Wizard
of Oz Dorothy picked up Soto used on
down the road all right have you been
counting at home how many times that
night gun to be eight do it three times
this is a draw here we come another kid
another pin but not bad with us but
we'll see nobody knows yes things things
are looking bleak but this game anything
can happen any second anything could
turn around you know you lose track of
one piece it's over my guess how many
people are you expected to come out to
this Metro class championship coming up
definitely over 50 we have an open
section well not an open section about a
master experts section with a a lot of
like thousand dollars in prizes so so if
you're a master expert thousand dollars
in prizes and then if your class ABCD
under 1200 / unrated there's five
sections for two hundred dollars so so
yep James is looking like he's going to
be in a class be right I try to get that
to all your bucks we should get some
supper need decent players to come out
for that so let's get some good numbers
we already have a new you spray a
champion ashish panda he's in it
it should be great you can only imagine
the results of those two plays like and
what would have happened all these
different excuses so Mario what is after
you make this move I got a good question
for you what is your built-in excuse for
for losing this match maybe didn't do
enough prep for this field never playing
classes before edit oh and he took
something see I can you tell i can rd
town looking good alright so JJ and job
I know where I got great news for you
you are Perry number one number one
that's fantastic I mean you'll get white
in the first two rounds of the
tournament excellent news for those two
who's up next oh we have a fan favorite
Grandmaster been fine gold and also
local a local player Joshua coalesce
yeah he's been around a lot lately
all right yes guy go all the way across
the board to get it nice see ya see ya
yeah and he died on his own square too
oh my god if you die at home and I guess
that's where you want to die right
sister anything on the night does not
look like you just borrow you know
something right now suppose it see if he
knows something he's a tricky guy Mario
is definitely known for playing tricky
bad that he couldn't get two pawns for
that night you know we take as much
stuff off the board up here goes a rook
and that looks like it's going to be the
a rook you numbers left with the check
okay we got a number two number two
excellent something else is getting
captured but I Oh think it's easier to
tell if these I don't see anything in
there next up for the Grand Master norm
is international master Nicholas chica
who played in the US Junior Championship
and also another junior championship
contender justice Williams quite a lot
of juniors in this one so that's gonna
be really exciting to watch we finally
moving inside again what did he go
all right some good numbers one bad no
we're still attend out there so this Oh
Mario you're lucky you're trying to sell
mate yourself here I'll explain hey go
away go away or something quick retreat
is humiliated round it's it is so far
away it was so far away and that's a
nope take some more stuff as well take
it excellent make some stuff
and that is uh oh number 8 has already
been claimed oh yeah number 8 has
already been claimed it was a joke it
was a joke it was you alright so
Nicholas chica and a justice way my
stolen Akane yeah right cuz it yeah it's
more confusing back here that it is on
the board what you make a queen to be
pawn alright so that is number three
yeah I confirmed it's great Nicholas
chica justice lame your three your half
of an eight so now we have a woman's US
Champion nhasi and girish Angkor make
more players looking for the number we
have five and ten
LightSquared bishop are charged gonna
play to the bitter end wait to take all
this stuff right just needs to be just
laugh at them take all the stuff now you
don't have to you can just check me as
fast is yeah just sorry players only
until we like one hour to watch this
video they're playing that go ah yeah
it's threatenings like g4 to trade stuff
this will be 5 attention good the more
attention the better more attention to
better take it don't see anything from
afar mario's that play by the rules
ain't just yet slow improving your
position what's the rush up right now is
a nazi and jury and then after that
we'll be pots of and angelo they'll
they'll just get whatever number is
remain Mario's not going down with a
fight just came back back home again oh
good there anything potentially just to
take an age fun for fun yep well oh
alright good you wanna have fun here it
is here it an excellent take it love it
doesn't look like it nope all right not
much else to do oh yeah
take your time yeah David oh yeah why
why why did I just go for me Mario does
here Oh Mario please don't like then
Simon here Dungey thought our so we are
still waiting on two numbers that is
that correct here alright so this is
this is the moment of truth here Mario
all right Mario why don't you any piece
you want your color his color not a lot
of years left but all right well we
where we lets us the champion where does
it first fishery one of the one of the
juices
all right okay there's obviously nothing
under the King because we knew that one
biggie captured well alright your turn
to take it to know right work right work
all right right rook hey there's a 10 in
there all right so let me now Z is 10
girls 10 katsu got five angelo young got
five and that is the result that's all
right and James I just want to ask you
real quick congratulations we'll see you
in the Metro class I'll give anything to
say about this game well the very
interesting game he had a good position
early on i blended the piece and he had
winning chances and I had anticipated
that he would come up smoking but I just
kept picking in the poking and pour them
into water only spoken in and he and I
was victorious very well said Mario we
always like to leave you with the last
words that you have anything to say
before we wrap this up continue to play
chess this was very nice like the the
glassware and hope to do this again
thank you very much to that will chat
hall of fame for letting us use their
direct submission here oh it's been
fantastic and we'll see you guys in
February for the winter Invitational
[Music]
you
[Music]